[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our
Shadowlands livestream I'm John Haight
executive producer for world of warcraft
we have a lot to tell you about today
but first I want to start by saying
thank you to our amazing community like
many of you our regular routines have
been turned upside down since we
quarantine and March we missing our
friends the daily greetings and
face-to-face conversations that we took
for granted they've been replaced by
webcam meetings little windows into each
other's homes when we meet this way we
often talk about how coded 19 and world
events are affecting our team and our
families and one of the hardest parts is
dealing with a feeling of helplessness
initially we struggled with maintaining
a sense of purpose but ultimately we
draw inspiration from all of you in a
situation where it's easy to feel
isolated our purpose is to help bring
people together Wow is truly a unique
and magical place where people can
maintain the bonds of friendship across
physical distance by joining forces to
take on epic challenges or just hang out
and talk and wow the journey together is
the real reward getting an awesome loot
upgrade finally downing a mythic rebus
defeating the enemy team in the last
moments of a battle all these
experiences are memorable because we
have each other to share them with
you've rekindled old friendships made
new ones and gathered in Azeroth to
honor fallen comrades seeing you all
connect in this way has helped us carry
on while it's also a place where you can
just do your own thing knowing that you
share a common bond with millions of
others for exploring the world with you
and who'll be there any time you want to
join up for an adventure - like many of
you we're eager to embark on a new
adventure together
you have our commitment
we will be releasing Shadowlands this
fall even if we end up shipping it from
our homes so again on behalf of the
entire Wow team thank you while this
stream is about Shadowlands before I get
to that I want to remind everyone what's
happening in wild classic later this
month on July 28th Wow classic will
Creek create one of the most
talked-about events in the game's
history the Ahn'Qiraj war players on
every realm across the world will gather
resources in a race to be the first to
acquire the scepter of the shifting
sands and open the gates of Ahn'Qiraj
signaling an epic war with the denizens
of this ancient and deadly temple I'm
looking forward to welcoming all of our
new scarab Lords now check this out I
just received our Shadowlands
collector's edition you can see on this
spine of the box looks like all the
collector's editions you've seen before
except we have these full-color covenant
emblems on the side so look great on the
Shelf with the other collector's
editions one of the really cool things
about this box is the front cover
it's literally exploding with color this
recreates the moment when Silvana's
broke the sky above Icecrown Citadel and
you can see a cool reflective material
inside you have the epic Edition which
includes the insertion everywhere mount
an animal wear bling pet a bunch of
digital goodies and 30 days of game time
you'll also find and this is something
we know you've all asked for so we did
one just for Shadowlands but here's the
art book beautiful for color art on
every page I'm sorry full-color art on
every page but has all the concept art
and a lot of great imagery there unique
to Shadowlands
and so you can also celebrate shadow
ends at your desk or home office
we have Shadowlands mousepad matches the
background behind me and then my
favorite component for this is we
actually have a collectors pin
collection this contains a pin for each
of the covenants Tyrion VIN the--our
necro lords and Knight fee it also
includes the soundtrack for Shadowlands
so you can listen to the music of the
afterlife wherever you go you'll be
experiencing more of Shadowlands very
soon in fact I'm pleased to announce
World of Warcraft Shadowlands will
officially enter beta next week
beta participants will be able to
experience the max level challenges in
the Maw the most dangerous place in all
the Shadowlands and one of the most
rewarding - to tell you more about our
upcoming beta I'd like to introduce our
game director ian has a costa's on
behalf of the WoW team thank you again
for your support everybody thank you
John thank you for sharing your morning
or evening with us as the case may be
super super hype to be able to share
that collector's edition with everybody
one of my favorite features that Jon
didn't get a chance to mention that
those pins actually have a self-destruct
mechanism built-in so pick one carefully
you want me on the other three might
vanish instantly let's talk a little bit
about what is coming up in the beta
ahead and Shadowlands in general so
first want to look back at the three
months since we launched our alpha it's
about three months ago to this day the
Alpha began and we welcomed thousands of
folks from around the world in to begin
to share this great project that we've
been working on really for the last
couple of years now at this point
journey through the four main zones the
Shadowlands seeing a glimpse of the maw
experience to covenant active abilities
and of course seeing tour guests our
valiant alpha
have completed over 800,000 quests in
that time over 2,000 unique characters
have finished exiles reach our new
player experience on the Alliance side
and ventured off to join the Alliance
and go to coal Terrace over 62,000 tour
gas drones have been undertaken on our
alpha servers and alas just over 11,000
of those ended in the clutches of the
terror group so be more careful next
time and crucially over 64,000 in-game
bug reports using our in-game reporting
tool have been entered by alpha testers
our QA team internally is busy poring
over those so far I think that
catalogued something like 1600 unique
bugs that are being tracked in our
system as a result of those reports
which will be fixed of course by the
time Shadowlands comes out and we know
that's just the tip of the iceberg this
is really you know an invaluable tool
and every bit of your feedback matters
speaking of feedback it's not just the
feedback within the tool but also
broader discussions on the forums and
the community at large on places like
Reddit and Twitter and the videos folks
are making to share reactions thoughts
and ways in which the experience that
they're seeing could be improved
something that our entire development
team is eagerly attentive to now our
alpha experience and our alpha process
really is a true alpha for the past
weeks what you have been seeing is the
active organic evolution of the game
sometimes a build might have a change
that literally is five days old it's an
experiment it's it's a solution to you
know some problem that was discovered
and we want to see what reactions are
immediately there's a very quick
turnaround time there and it's a
collaborative process between us and the
community and so you know we've seen
some changes to for example the pacing
of tour guests and the removal of any
sort of the de torment system or time
limits there the area in progress we've
heard a lot about also is frankly just
how much fun people are having and the
the grim prospect of only being able to
do it a certain number of times a week I
think we previously discussed that the
endless Carter section of tour guests
would be completely unguided but I'm
actually happy to announce that at this
we are shifting to completely remove all
King from all the wings of tour guests
and so you can run it to your heart's
content if you want to go in have fun
with a buddy try out a new build just
experience the dynamic gameplay of tar
gassed we don't want to get in your way
we'll figure out a solution to the
reward system there to make sure that
you're not required or overly encouraged
to you know endlessly grind it all week
but if you want to do it just because
it's fun we don't want to stop you of
course our class team is listening in
our combat team or listening to the
feedback there and there are regular
updates coming out and many more to
follow our level design team which you
know sculpts the hills and the mountains
and the roads that shape our zones are
actually eagerly devouring every bit of
footage of people playing the Alpha they
can get their hands on often watching
people who get turned around or confused
or stuck trying to climb up a hill that
looks like it should be climbing in
fixing those areas for the next build
the next week every part of the game are
character artists we're looking at
reactions to character customizations
that are going out and hearing what
people are most excited about what they
wish they could have what options are
missing and doing what they can to add
that so I can't thank all of you enough
both the people who are in the Alpha who
have been testing there for us but also
those who are sharing their thoughts as
part of a broader community conversation
the work that goes into Shadowlands is
you know as much yours as it is ours
truly
so now turning the corner looking ahead
to what the next weeks will hold as we
move into our beta so what is beta mean
for us Spada certainly means the game's
not done but the framework is there and
is complete there there shouldn't be
missing pieces giant missing ones where
it's an entire feature that's not there
or there's a zone that's not yet
playable while those things are true we
continue to call it alpha but we're
getting very close to you know pretty
much the the framework all being intact
being present and so the level cap is
going to go up to 60 when beta begins
it's also going to mean a first look at
our endgame systems at truely joining a
covenant visiting your covenant sanctum
playing through that content
through our outdoor world max level
content our max level dungeons are raids
experiencing soul binds and more there's
a lot of work still to be done to flesh
out the details of these systems but
everything should be there and that's
why we are now calling it beta now
perhaps most importantly for many of you
this also means a big new invite way of
going out that's gonna start next week
and a process that will continue as we
also want to you know maintain a lot of
concurrency on our test servers so we
can get feedback on what zones feel like
when there are dozens or hundreds of
people in there competing over spawns
trying to do quests together so thank
you to go to our online account options
check your settings there make sure that
you're opted in to warcraft beta if that
interests you and be patient don't get
frustrated if you don't get an email
from us right away we will continue to
do invites over the course of the summer
and as John said of course this kicks
off next week so I want to take the rest
of our time together just to talk a bit
about some of the things that you're
going to be seen as part of that end
game loop some of this is stuff that we
haven't really had a chance to say much
about since Blizzcon and so I wanted to
just share some more details and how the
designs have evolved since we last
discussed them so first off covenants as
we have said at great length
you know covenants are the centerpiece
of Shadowlands the Shadowlands expansion
this is where all roads lead as you
journey through the zones of the shadow
lands you will play through all four
zones you will meet the four controlling
powers of the shadow lands you get a
chance to borrow their powers get a
sense of their personalities their ethos
their aesthetic and at the end of that
road when you hit level 60 wood awaits
you is this fateful choice as you return
to aura bows now fully understanding the
stakes that are affecting the shadow
lands and really all of existence and
choose whether you want to cast your lot
with the quirian of Bastion the Venn
theory of Reverend wrath the neck
rewards of Meldrew axis or the knight
Fae Vardhan wield and as you make that
choice what that means is unlocking an
entire sphere of gameplay and content
for you what we've seen so far in alpha
really is just the tip of the iceberg
it's just these couple of active
abilities that you know you get to
experience by leveling up we also made
sure to make those testable as early as
possible just to get mechanical feedback
on them and what felt good and what
didn't but now it's time to see the rest
of the iceberg and everything the
covenants entail so on the system side
first off one of the most prominent
immediate things are going to experience
is soul binds so soul binding is this
ancient ritual in the Shadowlands
whereby two souls can link themselves to
each other sharing a portion of their
identity of their memories and also of
their powers and so as we join a
covenant you'll be able to form soul
binds with certain key powerful souls
that are affiliated with that covenant
these will be characters with vibrant
memorable personalities many of which
you will have met while leveling up and
while questing through those zones so
here let's I'm going to use the Venn
theour and Reverend Ruth for a lot of
these upcoming examples because that's
the first covenant that we're going to
have playable on an upcoming build no
idea the Miss blade is she was a a
renowned duelist in life and that
persona really shapes all of her
abilities and the ways in which she's
going to enhance your combat ability
grant you utility and more and so what
each soul line represents as you can see
in this slide it's effectively a talent
tree that you can you know you will
traverse down as you gain power in your
covenant you can pick which path you
want to go down customize your gameplay
you customize those abilities to suit
your gameplay now you may be noticing
the empty slots in this tree that's
where you're going to put these items
that are called conduits now for those
who played Legion you may remember
relics that you put into your artifact
weapon these are fairly similar conduits
are going to be items that you can get
from dungeon bosses raids PvP you know a
sort of wide array of max level item
sources and unlike the soul bind traits
which are universal where you know an
arms warrior and a holy priest have the
same traits if you have Nagi as your
soul bind conduits are spec specific
they will do things like improve your
ignore pain or your rejuvenation or
whatever huge
use to suck it there are different
conduit types some are going to focus on
increasing your throughput like your
damage and healing others are more about
survival others are about utility again
this is letting you mix and match to
choose the gameplay and the loadout that
really best suits whatever you're
looking to do on a given evening in
World of Warcraft now unlike covenants
which themselves are a very weighty
choice and not something that's lightly
switched salt lines have a great deal of
flexibility both in terms of respecting
them at a nominal cost nothing
escalating like how as a right wasn't
battle for Azeroth or just switching
from one sold line to another the same
way you might respect or switch talents
truly the idea here is to have a range
of options and you pick what suits you
for what you're looking to do right now
now as you join the sanctum and you join
the Covenant a key way in which you're
going to progress within your covenant
is by gaining renown renown will deepen
your connection with your soul binds it
will also unlock a wide range of
features rewards followers which we'll
talk about a little bit cosmetics and
more you'll earn renowned buy on a
weekly basis going out into the world
gathering anima this precious lifeblood
of the Shadowlands that every covenant
is starving for or by going into the maw
and rescuing tormented souls that really
rightfully belonged in your covenant in
your realm but that were instead cast
into the maw because of how the machine
of death is broken this isn't an
open-ended grind this isn't like
artifact power this is a more you know
metered progression as you're working on
behalf of your covenant and we're making
sure that really from the start the
moment Shadowlands launches we have
robust catch up systems built-in whether
you are and all to someone who switched
covenants or someone who's just you know
late coming to the game we don't want
you to feel like you're behind or like
you have some you know catch-up calendar
but renown is a primary way in which you
will progress through the systems of the
Covenant including soul bones but also
some stuff I'm about to talk about next
so each covenant has a sanctum now these
are yeah there's loose inspiration is
drawn here from things like the
Garrison's back in warlords or the class
halls in Legion
each sanctum is the base of operations
for that covenant and this is a place
where you're actually likely to begin
and end most of your gameplay sessions
once you're at max level who each
sanctum has a number of features to it
that you can upgrade but really restore
it to functionality because I think what
we're gonna learn now is we've entry
through the shadow lands is that this
was a vibrant place that had its own
ecosystem and politics and you know
people with various pastimes but all
this has been thrown into disarray as a
drought plagues the land everything is
withering starved of anima and chaos
really is consuming the Shadowlands and
you as a champion of your covenant will
be working to restore that order to
restore things to how they once were and
that will be largely accomplished by
getting anima rescuing souls from the
maw and restoring activating these
structures one of them that every
covenant has is a transportation network
so within your own zone if you are a
member of the night PHA with an Arden
wheel there's a complex route network
that lets you quickly access different
parts of the zone the Venn theory and
Reverend Ruth have a network of blood
mirrors that can basically teleport you
around we want to make it so that
critically is something that this is
something you're investing in you feel
most at home most comfortable in your
zone if you're a member of that given
covenant because that is where your
powers are greatest that is where
covenants influences greatest another
structure that every covenant has is
something called an anima conductor so
as I've mentioned you know part of the
plight of the Shadowlands is this lack
of anima groves in our queen Arden
wields that were once flourishing with
magical energy are now desiccated
withered temples in Bastion lie dormant
deactivated the constructs that once
guarded them are inactive anima is the
answer to all of those things and so
what you're doing as you bring it back
to your covenants into your sanctum is
pooling it in a reservoir but you also
have the ability to direct
the flow of anima outward toward your
zone to regrow reactivate these dormant
parts of the space now what that means
in gameplay terms is you can send a
stream of anima over to an area which
will enable quests treasures events
outdoor world content in that area for
you based on your choice on a given day
as you upgrade your anima conductor
you'll have more options that you can
unlock and as you engage in the system
in general you can progress towards
permanently enabling and reactivating
these spaces both so that you have the
content available for you but also so
that you see the world change around you
to an extent this Grove that once was
withered and dead in art and Weald will
once again be blooming and flourishing
with anima energy thanks to your efforts
and the events that were there will now
always be up for you as a result of what
you've done the third system that every
covenant has is a scouting map this is
an extension of the mission system that
we first introduced back in warlords of
Draenor and we've kind of tinkered with
that formula a couple times since then
and I think the basic loop there we've
moved away from its central importance
that I've had in more Lords and I think
we're not looking to go back to you know
the warlords ero version of this being a
source or the best raid gear in the game
or what have you but it's an outlet for
some storytelling some offline
progression so you have something
waiting for you where you log in and
something that you can maybe check in on
in shorter sessions but we want to add
more depth to the system than what we
had in the last couple of expansions
what we have previously really is just
it boils down to a coin flip you're
doing a simple matching game matching
counters to threats and maybe you've got
up to 170 percent success chance to get
your bonus reward and hope you get lucky
and really if you didn't cuz I think you
could have done better you don't think
you did right or wrong and it's either
it's you either succeed or fail we want
to re-envision the foundations of that
system to be something that is a better
analog to the fantasy that we're trying
to convey the way a mission works in
Warcraft isn't a coin flip the way
combat works in Warcraft when you're
sending these champions out into a
dangerous area is
success or failure it's nuanced gameplay
with tanks and healers and melee DPS and
ranged DPS as a party of combatants
fight a bunch of enemies and so this is
an abstracted form of that type of
combat it still will happen while you're
offline but there's a turn-based system
here where you will level up your soul
binds recruit additional champions and
adventurers to bolster their ranks and
send troops custom based on your
covenant out to complete these missions
and obviously bring back some of that
sweet loot that you're looking for
there's a lot of depth to the system
we're gonna have a early peek at it in
our next couple of builds and we'll
continue to add more you know breadth to
it over the course the beta really
curious to hear initial hands-on
impressions and as always with all of
our features we want to you know jump in
and react quickly to whatever feedback
we hear as before adventures will also
be supported in our mobile companion app
which will be updated for Shadowlands at
the time of the expansions release now
those three features that I just talked
about are something that every Covenant
has access to they are universal but
each covenant also has a fourth
structure that is unique depending on
which covenant you've joined now I've
been using Levin fear a lot burnings as
you know these examples so let's start
with them if you are event here in
Reverend Rev you also have this fourth
section of your sanctum known as the
ember court and what the ember court is
it's basically it's a hosting venue for
pretty rad parties if you know the the
culture of Rev and Ruth certainly before
things really went off the rails and the
events leading up to this expansion was
one of elegance aristocracy a lot of
those new tropes surrounding nobility
and part of what that means is showing
off your influence by hosting grand
galas for the most important individuals
not just from Reverend drift but from
across the Shadowlands as a whole and
the venn --there were notorious for this
now your ally as you joined the venn
theour prince rena fell is looking to
reestablish himself to reestablish a new
order and showing off his growing
influence and stature in that area and
you're gonna help him out as a loyal
member of his covenant no way that's
going to play out is what's effectively
you know
a self-contained minigame where you can
go out seek out guests invite them to
the party not maybe literally arrange
catering but figure out the different
services that are going to make those
guests happy play through the party in
real time
maybe fending off party crashers that
are trying to disrupt the festivities
and at the end of the day maximizing the
happiness of all your guests and ideally
if they're happy on the way out they'll
give you a token of their gratitude in
the form of well suite or craft loot I
want to be clear this is not gloom and
doom life or death saving the Shadowland
stuff this is just a fun side activity
that has a remarkable amount of depth to
it but is there to you know allow us to
flesh out the culture and the
personality and the identities of these
covenants of these areas
you're not going to defeat the jailer by
throwing the most badass party in the
Shadowlands
but that is part of what being event
here is now if on the other hand you
join the Curia in Bastion very unique
feature is called the path of Ascension
now the path of Ascension is is driven
by this unique soul mirror whereby you
can actually inhabit the consciousness
of one of your soul binds so you can
play let's say as the aspirant Pella
goes with a unique set of abilities and
go through a series of trials
gladiatorial combat against the most
powerful souls of the Shadowlands that
you will also go out in your adventures
across the world and recruit and capture
and bring back to fight within the path
of Ascension this is a self-contained
combat heavy system that has a little
bit of a boss rush feel to it for those
of you who are very old school if you
remember the shark to Levent
way back in Burning Crusade and blades
edge mountains this is loosely inspired
by that it's the same kind of vibe and
this is available to members of the
keyring now if you joined the necro
Lords of meld Raxus necro Lords are and
meld Roxas is the source of the military
might of the Shadowlands this is a lot
of a power that we saw manifested by the
scourge in the great floating Acropolis
is like next ramus and you know
abominations like patchwork and ghouls
and Geist's and the art of creating
those creatures the art of necromancy
is most closely affiliated with Mulder
axis and so the structure you have as a
member of the necro lords is called the
abomination Factory and this is a system
whereby you can you know build you know
flesh work creature is essentially
whether it's an abomination or a ghoul
or a Geist to be the perfect housing for
a soul that's in need of a physical form
now these Souls have quirks and unique
personalities and interests and
abilities so as you meet them figure out
what the right form for them is and
create a body for them to house you can
then adventure with them unlocking
various perks ranging from utility extra
gathering bonuses to some combat perks
in the outdoor world and again as always
this is available to necro Lords only
finally if you're a member of the knight
Fae of Arden wield Arden milk contains
its innermost reaches a sacred grove
known as the Queen's conservatory this
is where powerful Souls effectively
germinate rest are infused with the
surrounding energies of the forest and
are prepared for rebirth and returned
the world of the living because that is
the essential function one of the
essential properties of Arden wield now
the form that that takes for you as a
player this is effectively a soul garden
and it is inspired and has some
parallels to the farm back in
Mississippi Pandaria where you are
tending your own plots you are expanding
them upgrading them Bini and being able
to you know effectively fertilize them
with different catalysts that are going
to shape the consciousness of these
souls as you nurture them back to life
so it's a bit more magical but the end
of the day its own branch of
self-contained gameplay and really one
of the core ideas behind this variety of
features is to you know reinforce the
breath of what covenant choice is all
about and to make your difference your
experience slightly different from that
of your peers as we journey through the
Shadowlands or when you're jumping at an
alt and checking out a different
covenant giving you a whole set of new
fresh systems to explore and experience
there so what will have a lot more to
talk about with sanctums we'll have deep
dive blogs on individual pieces of these
over the course the summer as beta
progresses but that's an overview of
some of the new stuff you're going to
seeing in covenants as beta begins now
some other new content we are going to
have coming up our last dungeon that we
have not yet revealed a max level
dungeon called the theater of pain
Theatre of pain is a dungeon in the
center of Melcher axis and this is
really it's an epic arena and the the
dungeon takes place during an important
event there's this regularly recurring
battle royale effectively where all of
that war houses of madra axis send their
greatest champions to fight to fight it
out and to prove who is the strongest
who is the most powerful of all because
that's a lot of what Melcher axis is
about it's its might makes right is the
prevailing ethos there and
demonstrations of power and military
might and cunning now this has you know
there are particularly complex layers to
what's going on right now given the
strife was gripping the Shadowlands that
make these particular games perhaps the
most important in the weightiest in
recent memory and you find yourself as
an adventurer as a party of adventurers
plunged into this conflict and the way
that's going to play out is is a very
non leaning your dungeon experience as
you choose which of the different
factions you're going to engage with
first as you traverse the you know the
catacombs the tunnels beneath the arena
ultimately culminating in a final
encounter where we'll see if you work
well the five of you can emerge
victorious as the ultimate champions of
the theatre of pain and as with all you
know at all things meld Raxus the
prevailing decor here is super metal so
expect more of that as you enter this
dungeon next up we are going to be
revisiting the outdoor space of the maw
so this is really where it all began for
us in the shadow line so we just saw a
couple of weeks ago in alpha those
initial and that initial venture into
the maw the domain of the jailer as we
went in from Icecrown stood at all not
knowing what was going to await us on
the other side what we found was
horrific array of forces that we can't
hope to overcome we just barely escaped
from the jailers clutches and made it
out in two or Beauce we could then
explore the rest of the Shadowlands well
now as we hit level 60 as we are in max
level with the power of a covenant
behind us
it's going to be time for us to return
to this place where it all began to go
into the maw with the goal of
investigating exploring trying to
understand more of what the jailer is up
to and how we might fort those plants so
fortunately early on in our visits into
the mall we're going to encounter
probably the one singular being in all
of the mob who doesn't actively want to
kill us at least as far as we can tell
this mysterious Broker known as Benari
Benari is kind of huddled away in a
small cave in the outer reaches of the
maw and you will be able to work with
her to investigate and explore gather
precious artifacts and resources from
throughout the mall that will maybe make
it a little bit more of a hospitable
place for you give you more information
increase your ability to traverse the
mall as well as improve your
effectiveness in tour guests the MA is
really inspired by a lot of our set more
Sandboxie and game content in the past
most recently probably mecha Don from
the rise of a Shara patch that we had
the middle of battle for Azeroth but you
know those roots go all the way back to
places like timeless Isle this isn't a
place where you're going to bring up
your map and see a bunch of world quests
and clear direction it's more about a
loose structure general broad objectives
and then lots and lots of discoverable
gameplay so we can't wait to have people
jump in here let us know what you think
and and one of the really fun challenges
in creating this experience was trying
to create gameplay that reflects the
fantasy of the space you are not welcome
here this is not a place full of flight
paths and ends to set your hearthstone
and people who are welcoming you at
every turn everything in the mall
rejects your very existence and presence
there you do not belong here and
everything you do is under the watchful
eye of the jailer where if you you know
raise a bit too much of a ruckus you're
engaging in you know you'd be making a
bit too much noise
fighting too many big champions calling
you they can't be attention to the
jailer upon you you're gonna need to
beat a hasty retreat if you want to get
out there and you're going to escape
with your life and your hard-won
earnings intact so I'd like to share
with you a quick video that's just a
look at what the Maas like in
[Music]
all right so yeah it's like it's super
it's super desolate place but on spiring
in in a terrible way
so those are some of the specifics that
we've you know just covered I also want
to lay out a bit more of what lies ahead
as beta unfolds across the summer later
this month we'll be kicking off formal
raid testing of our Castle Nath VII raid
this is a ten boss raid in the zone of
Reverend Ruth where you're ultimately
going to face off against the Venn
theory Lord Denarius who is one of the
major power players in the Shadowlands
it's just incredible gothic fantasy our
encounter team and our dungeon art team
had a blast making this we can't wait to
get people in there as always we'll have
focused testing windows for normal
heroic mythic and rate finder
difficulties and as we get on in the
beta will be looking to specifically
have some targeted invites for
experienced traders who can give us the
feedback that we need to get the tuning
right on difficulties like mythic also
later this month we'll be kicking off
shadow lands mythic Keystone dungeons we
want to get these in your hands as
quickly as possible as soon as max level
content is unlocked you want to enable
mythic Keystone's we'll probably have a
vendor that just sells Keystone's
directly just to facilitate testing
early on we just want to get initial
feedback on how our dungeons are playing
with the core mythic plus affixes so we
can hear quickly you know where things
like bolstering or necrotic or bursting
are extra frustrating and make sure that
we're making any tweaks early on to make
the experience that you have ultimately
when Shadowlands comes out the best one
possible later on and beta will also be
revealing for focus testing our first
Shadowlands seasonal ethics as well as
some potential other tweaks to the
system
legendary runecrafting is something
we're really excited to let people get
their hands on this is something we
talked about way back at Blizzcon and
this is the expression of legendary
items in shadow lands so for those of
you who remember Legion and really
throughout the history of World of
Warcraft some of the coolest loot we've
ever made has had that orange color
orange border when you see a legendary
item it's usually something that's going
to transform your gameplay and unlock
all
level of power within you and one of the
big points of feedback that we got that
was frustrating in Legion was centered
around how these items were attained and
you know the lack of control over
obtaining them the wrapping item that
was tremendously powerful you'd seen
videos featuring it you were really
excited to get it but there was nothing
you could do to earn it you felt unless
you got lucky Shadowlands is really
aiming from the outset to address those
concerns and to give you a ton of agency
and control over how you seek out and
earn your Legendary's so early on as you
venture in to tour guest tower of the
Damned you're going to encounter this
mysterious ruins myth whose chained up
shackled in a Hannibal Lecter style cell
in the bowels of Tor gassed and what
you'll learn pretty early on is that
this room Smith wields some of the same
power that power of domination that was
once used to craft incredible artifacts
like Frostmourne or the now shattered
helm of the lich king and by recovering
essence from - our guest as well as
scraps of this ancient rune acknowledge
that you can bring back to the Smith and
awaken locked away memories the rune
Smith will be able to make for you to
imbue an item with power that you get
from a tailor blacksmith leather work or
depending on your on you know your armor
type the rune Smith can make a legendary
of your choice for you that way you can
look at those amazing bracers or gloves
or boots or whatever you're seeking and
work towards it earn it and then begin
your next project a lot of these
legendary powers are throwbacks to some
fan favorites from across really the
past dozen years everything from Legion
legendaries to old set bonuses to powers
that are brand new tour guests powers
that you'll be able to you know use
temporarily within tour guests but
sometimes permanently imbue a legendary
item with as part of the idea is really
this ancient runic art is the source of
many of those powers items from the
shadow lands that have found their way
out into the world over the over the
years and finally they can be yours
covenant campaigns so I didn't touch on
this when we're talking about covenants
earlier but each covenant once you join
them has a max level narrative quest arc
associated with it
this is similar to the war campaign that
we had in battle for Azeroth where there
there was an alliance campaign in a
horde campaign this time around there
are four distinct campaigns of roughly
that size and scope depending on your
covenant and through playing through
this you will earn cosmetic rewards for
your covenant on law conditional soul
bind and really experience the full
extent of your covenants perspective on
the world and the events the shadow
lines also before too long in beta we
want to kick off some focus to PvP
testing you want to set up an
environment where we can unlock all of
these systems we're not trying to test
the progression and the rate at which
you earn them here but we want to just
let you have access to solve ions
conduits legendaries all the rest and
get early and rapid iteration on arena
battlegrounds just general PvP combat
testing at max level so that we can make
sure that we're both reigning in any
outliers but also just dialing in the
overall pacing of combat you know no one
no one likes those matches that go into
super high dampening the other end of
the spectrum
no one wants matches that are over in 20
seconds in some crazy burst or proc
window so the earlier we can get that in
front of you the earlier sooner we can
start really dining it into what it
needs to be as part of that also it's
kind of the opposite in the spectrum we
do want to test the pacing of
progression and rewards and the way at
which the rate at which things are
earned and to make that as organic as
possible will be probably wiping the
existing characters that people have had
in the Alpha environment probably by the
end of this month and enabling character
copies which will set up end to end
testing as you can come in with your
characters from battle for Azeroth level
up through shadow lands replace your
gear organically or in the rewards
you're gonna earn and start giving us
feedback on how all of that feels so I
think one of the things we've learned
over the years and making these
expansions is there's a whole lot that
goes into them there's a ton of moving
parts is a ton of systems and we can
make our best guesses as to how players
are going to interact with them but
there's no real substitute for having
the whole thing stood up and and having
people go through it and rather than
having those regrets that we sometimes
have a month or two into an expansion
where we realized we missed the mark on
some aspect of that progression we want
to really do as much of it as possible
during beta so that when the game comes
out for real
it's everything that it needs to be and
that's really the theme of the month
ahead we have some work to do to finish
fleshing out the structures that we've
just described but most of the rest is
going to be polish responded to feedback
iteration and finally tuning let me talk
a little bit about tuning because I know
it's a hot topic balance is always you
know the most controversial one of the
most central topics in community
discussion and has been forever in WoW
tuning is the last thing that we do in
the early parts of alpha and beta
we're Masonville basically just looking
for extreme outliers where things might
be so far out of whack they disrupt the
feedback that we get if something is so
overpowered that it trivializes content
well we have to fix that otherwise all
of our feedback on let's say tor ghast
is going to be tainted because someone's
walking through one shotting things or
something is so weak that doesn't matter
if it's theoretically fun it feels
terrible to use or no one wants to use
it we don't get feedback on it we need
to fix that but beyond that we really
want to focus first on shoring up the
conceptual foundations of what we're
building we want to make sure the
abilities the systems and everything
else feel fun that this that they sound
exciting as ideas and then once we've
gotten to a place where we're confident
in those foundations the natural next
step is to dial them in so that they're
well tuned and so if you're looking at
the way things are in alpha now and
saying to yourself that I don't know
hypothetically speaking the best choices
are 40% better than what you might pick
if you were just trying to you know go
after what looks fun that's because
there's a key part of the stuff the
process here that just hasn't happened
yet now I don't want to say you know yep
you know just wait until after beta it's
only data we sent we sometimes get that
wrong too but there's a deliberate
process that we approach for a reason if
you want to make sure that we're using
the majority of our bandwidth to fix bad
ideas rather than potentially trying to
polish something that ultimately is
fundamentally flawed so for example
we've heard a lot of feedback recently
on the Arden Weald paladin ability of
covenant ability blessing of seasons
and I try to different a couple
different versions of that ultimately
we're at this point going to go back the
drawing board and fundamentally redesign
the way that ability works because it
has some some fundamental flaws that
make it very challenging to balance but
also not even necessarily as fun as we'd
hoped it would be and so having put a
lot of effort into tuning that would
have potentially masked an underlying
problem or at best has been a
distraction from the more important work
that we could have been given in the
meantime and so as the you know sort of
original creative work of Shadowlands
comes to a close as we move out of that
phase the phase that lies ahead of us is
going to have lots and lots of tuning
and polish that will continue all the
way up to launch for the expansion later
this year
so I want to say thank you thank you for
joining us today and I also want to
thank you all for your patience we
originally planned on doing this dream a
month ago and back then we would have
had somewhat different material but we
postponed it then to avoid distracting
from a more important conversation but
of course that conversation is still
happening injustice doesn't cease just
because we look away black lives matter
at a month ago black lives matter today
and if that phrase is difficult to hear
know that I and others who speak those
words aren't saying that your life has
any less worth we're only calling
attention to the ways in which our
societies seem to need a reminder the
black lives matter now as John said
earlier these are extraordinarily
difficult times we all have our own
struggles and we can often help by
simply listening with open hearts so be
kind to one another
stay safe and we'll see you in Azeroth
and the shadow lands beyond thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]